I'm gonna beat the holy hell
and one of you
yes me
since you're in the club now you have to
wear the hat
we'll be done I love you bye I believe
this one blue file over
you don't need a picture me you never
will again catch the tiger you're doing
this cuz you want to die
we can find a way
I'm still with you
we can make it dull
wherever we all wind up you win a man
I've changed adapted I'm a survivor Pig
we fight
we do it together
all of us
are
did
I won't let you die out there
everything's his or will be there are
rules you earn when you take whatever
he's done to you
there's always we should have made a
deal with them when we could have you
should know there is no door number four
this is the only way
ah
I don't know what the hell's going on in
the most wonderful way
I am king Ezekiel welcome to the kingdom
hey youtubers is Charlie we have a tiger
this is like Walking Dead's we have a
Hulk moment so let's break it down
really big montage here of all the
characters that are lined up by negan
like if you guys didn't know like that's
why they hit all these characters beats
reminding you all the big character arts
they tried to set up last season hitting
all the relationships like you have
Glenn Maggie this baby that they might
be happening this potential future
they're trying to build that we might
miss out on because one of these
characters is definitely going to die
whatever your complaints were about the
finale about the things that they did
not do like the big cliffhanger with
negan Robert Kirkman did say that they
would satisfy all that in the premiere
so I wouldn't say I'm like I'm
necessarily super connected to any of
these characters in a way it would make
me really upset if they were to die like
if you've read the comic you know a
certain character in particular dies so
you're probably expecting that but
because the TV show is deviated from the
comic especially in earlier seasons you
really just can't say like it's going to
be exactly like it is in the comics but
when they do comic book things they are
definitely 100% faithful so like the
really big moments like negan's
introduction his speech is ripped right
out of the comics so there are two
really big things that they're hyping up
in this trailer
one is negan finally feeding one of the
survivors to Lucille 2 is setting up
what's going on with the rest of the
season this is a wider world like I
think that was an actual line from his
far back a season 5 maybe it was early
season 6 it was when they were first
getting settled in the safe zone like
they were learning oh my god there's
this huge community but wait there are
many more communities so now we're just
getting to see some of those other
communities they're building the world
out in the one big new place is the
Kingdom like we've already met the
Savior's one of their you know big main
bases is called the foundry the other
place that we've only teetley we haven't
been to but we've met some of the people
from there is the kingdom that's where
those people in the armor are that Rick
and Morgan ran into the really
interesting thing about them is that
even though they seem really helpful
they have Ezekiel here is kind of like
their leader he has his Tiger it's named
Shiva I'm so happy they're doing the
tiger it's a big thing in the comics and
it's so hard to do big animals like that
on TV
that I can't wait to see the behind the
scenes of how they actually got it to
act in scenes like it's usually really
expensive and time-consuming to do stuff
like that so the villain is obviously
negan like that you know very clearly
positioning him is the biggest of big
bats that we've ever seen way worse than
the governor
you kind of get a sense of it when he's
talking but one of the things that you
know Robert Kirkman said that he really
likes about negan that makes him so
terrifying is because he's so
charismatic like he just talked to you
forever like give you this really
impassioned speech and then just
completely come off like he was
bullshitting you the whole time so you
never really know when he's telling the
truth
and I think you know Robert Kirkman
joked that he was a used car salesman
before the apocalypse so it looks like
we're getting some better shots of the
foundry here with Dwight more of negan
with a bloody Lucille and just kind of
walking around pretty safe to say this
bloody shot of the bat is from that
first episode like right after he bashes
one of their brains in more of Jesus
being a badass one of the big reasons
especially in the comics you know for
Robert Kirkman writing in all these
other new characters is you just kind of
fresh in the story up like you shake
things up you expand the world it gives
you the opportunity to bring in a bunch
of new people and change the narrative
really like the biggest things I'm most
excited for though are seeing the actual
play like the actual foundry meeting
some of the other Savior's not all of
them are terrible like I know you know
you see negan and you think that they're
all psychopaths but some of them are
also just totally normal people that are
trying to survive and they just they
just have to do whatever negan says like
that's part of the terms of the
agreement like you have to give him half
your stuff I say by comparison the
kingdom is a little bit closer to the
safe zone it's a little more hardcore
like as you can see they're all armored
up they're a little more warlike but
Ezekiel isn't like a complete crazy
person in the way that negan is like
he's the other side of the coin like
things are getting crazier but like
negan is the bad side of that the
kingdom in Ezekiel is the good side of
that I know he says his name is king
Ezekiel welcome to the kingdom but he's
not as crazy as he sounds like he's not
negan level crazy let me know what you
guys think of the trailer like are you
really excited for Ezekiel the kingdom
obviously everyone's kind of pumped for
negan just because he and Lucille are
gonna shake things up so much and I
think everybody just kind of waiting for
that payoff the only other time I think
people have screamed for blood this much
was when Olly betrayed Jon Snow on Game
of Thrones during season five so
actually that's another good question
let me know in the comments who do you
think is getting the business end of
Lucille do you think it's going to be
like in the comic books if you have read
the comics and you want to talk about is
Eko the Kingdom or any of that stuff or
you know who gets loose sealed in the
comics just please use spoiler tags but
if you guys did know in related Comic
Con news like where day two of Comic Con
is coming to a close as I'm making this
video day three Saturday is going to be
all Marvel and DC there's a whole bunch
of
TV and movie trailers are going to be
dropping I will be live-tweeting all
that stuff here are the links for that
if you guys want to follow along why you
guys wait for that to post you can click
here for the first real Game of Thrones
Season 7 teaser trailer and you can
click here for all the Marvel Netflix
stuff thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you